russia calls it relief for the world
these shipments contain the vaccine
candidate sputnik
two thousand venezuelans will try it out
including a member of the presidential
family
in this clinical trial phase my son
nicolas ernesto maduro guerra
told me of his decision to be vaccinated
with the russian vaccine
to join the trial i think it's very good
belarus was the first foreign country to
receive batches of the vaccine last week
india is also interested in testing it
for russia it could be a sputnik moment
like the one in 1957
when the communists launched the first
satellite
[Music]
in august russia declared itself the
first country to approve a coronavirus
vaccine
high-risk groups have been receiving
sputnik 5 health workers journalists
teachers alongside china russia has been
deploying the shots before
full efficacy trials are complete the
results are promising
the vaccine has been met with some
skepticism
washing his hands multiple times a day
just one of a series of hygiene measures
samyang galperin undertakes
the doctor doesn't want to take any
chances with coronavirus
but he knows a vaccine would offer the
best protection against
covet 19. that's why he's volunteered to
take part in testing a new russian one
someone has to do it without clinical
trials there are no medicines
the effectiveness of a vaccine can only
be evaluated in the third phase of
clinical trials
stage three of the trials began a month
ago
but the vaccine which has been named
sputnik 5
was licensed already in august before
they began
mass inoculation in russia is planned
for later this year
something numerous experts have sharply
criticized
the russian government rejects the
criticism it says the vaccine
has been developed from already known
substances and doesn't pose any health
risks
russia urgently needs an effective
vaccine
the country currently has the fourth
highest number of coronavirus cases
worldwide
and the numbers continue to rise with
around six thousand new infections
each day galbrain and other doctors
working
say they are not worried about the
vaccine safety
after all the vaccine has already been
tested on several well-known public
people
and they're doing quite well
these public figures include russian
defense minister sergey shoigu
moscow mayor sergey sobianin and one of
president vladimir putin's daughters
important pr material
it's part of russia's strategic
interests to always want to be first
irrespective of whether it's a
revolution or the first flight into
space
now it's about saying that we're the
first to develop a vaccine
internally we're showing that the
situation is
under control externally it's a signal
that russia
is still mastering its role as savior of
the world
semyon galperin isn't thinking about his
country's pr plans just now
the doctor is here because he's hoping
to help win the fight
against the coronavirus pandemic
they want it to be over the new vaccine
would help
calm people and offer a way out of the
situation
it will most likely be at least several
months until the results of the phase 3
trials
are known only then can the actual
effectiveness and safety
of russia's sputnik 5 vaccine be
assessed
noah batsif works at the international
vaccine access center at the johns
hopkins bloomberg school of public
health
so will the russians be the first
uh look there are lots we want lots of
people to achieve a vaccine it's not
about who's going to be first it's about
as many people as can cross the finish
line really to have a safe
and effective vaccines we want multiple
winners here
the russian vaccine is certainly you
know doing
moving interface large scale phase
threes as are many others
and we want licensure to occur after the
completion of those phase threes when we
have good safety data
and good efficacy data that the vaccines
actually work
um so lots of people we want to succeed
here not just
one group over another on the point of
safety
have the russians been fudging the
numbers as some have
accused and skipping parts of the trials
there's no good solid evidence that
there's been any concern about the
numbers the
the detail that was given in the russian
papers uh
the paper was excellent you know the
quality of the evidence
was as solid as any of the other
published papers
um the there have been some uh lay
reports on blogs and so on those really
don't hold water when examined uh
thoroughly and statistically
so no i i don't have any more concerns
about this group than any other group
particularly now now the modified common
cold viruses behind such vaccines have
been studied
for decades but are still not widely
used why
why is that um
there are a number of other vaccine
platforms that have we have a lot more
experience with
um the advantage of adenovirus vectored
vaccines
is that they are potentially capable of
delivering
almost any antigen to the immune system
and so there
and the vector itself is designed to be
non-replicating so it can't cause
infection
the capacity to do that the capacity to
develop these
vaccines has been in development for
quite a long time but only recently has
reached licensure under the pressure
really of developing a vaccine against
ebola virus and that's been a success
so that's good and we we'd like to see
more of these vaccines going forward
clearly we need lots more experience
with them particularly around safety and
around efficacy
but there's no reason to suspect that
there'll be problematic vaccines in fact
they're likely to be very good vaccines
when you have a range of potential
adenovirus vectors
some are more frequently encountered by
human populations than others
then there are differences potentially
that could arise among the different
products and that's some of the
detail that's coming up from some of the
scientific literature but as a platform
it
you know it's a really exciting platform
and we hope that there'll be lots of
opportunity to develop this platform
with vaccinology beyond this pandemic
into the future also
what what's the certainty though that
vaccines that pass phase three will be
successful
for the wider population
there's never certainty you know science
is built on uncertainty
and falsifiability so it's really
important that our methods are as
rigorous as they can be
and it's important that we continue to
evaluate the vaccine even after
it's rolled out and even after it
achieves licensure in phase three
phase three trials are the trials that
demonstrate large scale you know in
terms of
tens of thousands and collectively close
to hundreds of thousands of people
at safety in trial participants
and importantly efficacy against disease
so it actually protects human beings
against disease
that's the minimum that we require for
licensure
if a vaccine is very rarely harmful it
causes
you know serious harm very rarely then
society has to weigh up the pros and
cons as with all vaccines
they all are potentially harmful but
very rarely so
but they're very very beneficial and
frequently so
so it's always a question of balancing
the risks and benefits and that correct
balance requires good science
good surveillance and good evidence
going forward beyond phase three and
beyond licensure
well into many years of hopefully future
use
you've said it's problematic if a
vaccine is designed to target the
disease and not
the infection why
well it's not exactly right but you're
close i mean all vaccines really are
designed to target
disease but clearly we're facing a
complex situation currently with
coronavirus because we have widespread
infection and transmission occurring
globally
i think the public expectation is that
once a vaccine is available we go back
to the way things were
and we stop masks and we stop social
distancing
and and that's a misjudgment of what a
vaccine at least in the initial phase
can do
the aim of the vaccine is to reduce
disease and to reduce it in vulnerable
groups at least initially in the first
round of vaccination if a vaccine is
only given to those
at high risk and not to everybody
clearly transmission will continue to
occur
in those who didn't receive the vaccine
but even in a year from now or a year
and a half from now
or two years from now when the vaccine
is more widely available
it'll be critical to demonstrate that it
actually reduces transmission and not
just reduces
disease because if it doesn't do that
then the only other ways to reduce
transmission are to continue with face
masks and so on
um one could imagine a paradox whereby
if the vaccine continues
to allow transmission and works less
well to protect against disease in the
elderly that you know paradoxically
his adverse outcomes could get worse not
not better
so we need to be very careful about how
we deploy vaccines on the basis of the
best available science and evidence
around
what they do what their efficacy is
against naubatsy thank you very much for
joining us
thank you for having me and it's that
part of the show when we look at your
questions on the coronavirus
is dw science correspondent derek
williams
are any countries testing school-age
kids on a wide scale
too if so what are the results
because covet 19 in general at least
doesn't affect children as severely as
older people kids in general have not
been tested as much throughout the
pandemic it's
simply been a question of resource
allocation
but the lack of really solid data has
also led to a lot of speculation that
kids might not be much of a factor
in spreading the disease throughout
wider society which
has in some countries influenced things
like
decisions to reopen schools but now
a big study from india could cause
authorities
to rethink that idea it focused among
other things on
contact tracing data from 85 000
confirmed cases
in two states there in total it looked
at test results from over five hundred
thousand
contacts that occurred between people
who were infected
and the people they gave it to or didn't
give it to and one of the most
interesting takeaways was that it showed
kids actually do
pass the disease on to other kids
especially
those in their age group which would
include for example
kids in the same class at school what
the study
wasn't able to clarify was was how often
those kids
subsequently might have passed the virus
along to adults
but but even so the evidence now looks
pretty compelling it indicates that the
idea that kids don't really spread covet
19
doesn't really hold water which a lot of
researchers have said
shouldn't actually come as a surprise